[Music]
Kito is more than a thousand kilometers
from Venezuela yet some people who have
fled the chaos there have made it to the
Ecuadorian capital on foot about 50 of
them live in this compound at the edge
of the city and keep busy tending the
kitchen garden when I water the garden I
always think of my house back home in
Venezuela we used to water the garden
every evening it relieves the stress
this garden was set up with the help of
the city backed participatory urban
agriculture program a group are so far
the gardener's eat what they grow it's a
step towards self-sufficiency Jose sorry
Yaga and his family fled Venezuela last
autumn they threatened me and said we
should leave the country because we were
not cooperative and were therefore
traitors the comb here stands in stark
contrast to the commotion and crisis
back home coming here the Santeria has
left everything and everyone behind
I left Venezuela with my wife and Marie
and the four of us we have a house there
and we let the opposition use it while
they were preparing for the elections
the refugees here work together in the
garden they help each other
some already know about farming and can
instruct the others you plant a seed
here my group are has had an impressive
impact with its participatory approach
involving the most vulnerable groups are
friends from Venezuela need help with
this project we can offer support to
migrants and refugees in our country so
they can find some stability and
integrate in our society this is just
one of 4000 urban farming plots across
Quito supported by a group are ranging
from a few square meters on a rooftop to
laura geodes at the edge of town the aim
in each case is to ease access to
healthy food for poor and marginalized
people the greenery also helps improve
air quality and quality of life the
increase in biodiversity in the area
reduces urban heat islands creates new
spaces and micro climates in which
people can have a better life over the
past four decades Quito has grown almost
fivefold the population has tripled to
more than two and a half million a group
ah helps further food security job
creation environmental management social
inclusion and gender equality
Yano grande used to be a tranquil
village until it was swallowed up by the
city but some open spaces survived and
can be used to grow food a group of
women run this urban farm their work
marks a courageous break with tradition
the early phase of our organization was
very difficult because we had to deal
with them but she's more of our husbands
know we shouldn't do it it was a waste
of time
but it was a spoke of but little by
little we proved that our value as women
goes beyond being mothers we can do all
kinds of things including tending the
land and feeding our families we can
contribute economically I grew up our
staff regularly visit and bring advice
on how to run their ventures - das
there's always more to learn about
farming methods and increasing the
yields oh what a lovely garden a grouper
is committed to organic farming without
chemical fertilizers the women of Yano
grande grow so much produce now they
have some to sell promoting organic
farming the project has also helped
create skills especially among women
that allow them to make a living through
agriculture there's the liquid or the
urban farmers can sell their crops at
special organic produce markets boeuf
arias when we started we didn't even
know how to do the bookkeeping but now
we know more we're learning to grow as
individuals and above all we're partners
in the community urban gardening
projects around the world book - a group
are as a model the pioneering
organization is continuing to expand in
Quito the area devoted to urban farming
here in Quito is growing about 3
hectares or about 200 different plots
each year for the refugees from
Venezuela urban farming might prove the
first step to a new life